due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the coven
19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
personal to executive order 202004
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the executive
order i am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability
to communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
media platform
and the public has access to
contemporary geniusly listen
and if invited participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar of the general
report
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91k
anyone has a problem accessing the
meeting
please call 271 3600 or email
hcs.state.nh.org
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned
we'll start the meeting by taking the
roll call attendance
on each member of state's presence
please also state whether there's anyone
in the room with
representative fellows phone alone
representative i am present at home
and my wife is in the house with me
representative goalie
i am home and my wife is in the other
room
representative i'm in my home office
and i'm alone representative judy
we miss you just realized that i want
you
because he's there in his car um
representative lonzarro i home in nashua
and uh some family throughout the house
representative
president in the committee room
representative mcguire president in the
committee room
representative o'brien
president uh i'm at home alone in
nashville
here in the committee room
representative schmidt
i am president in my home office in
dover and i'm alone
representative president at my home
in pembroke alone representative schultz
i am in my home in concord and my
husband will be in and out of the room
excellent we have uh our last two senate
bills to do
senate bill 133 and senate bill
uh 155 so i'm going to move
ought to pass on senate bill 133
and present amendment 1579
h i'll second that
actually you're moving adoption of the
amendment
[Music]
this amendment is has been voted on each
section
individually uh it includes the update
to section 12 that we voted on
uh with telepaths
it's now part nine but it's the same
section
and uh
so all in all it's we've all voted on
this before
we all the pieces have been included
and uh
it's time to get this this sucker out of
here
representative pearson used to speak to
it
it was so eloquently described by you i
i don't dare try to change it
and if does anyone else wish to speak on
senate bill on the amendment to senate
bill 133
madam chair thank you
just verifying uh this does include the
child day care provision that we talked
about
should yes
it's on page 48 starting on line 26
thank you i'm with so many pages it's
hard to find
thank you it's the very last part
i see it there thank you
rather shock myself to be uh
recommending a 50-page amendment but
these things can happen
representation do you have another
comment
i'm sorry say again did you have another
oh i'm sorry did i still have my hand up
yes you put it back
up in fact representative
yes thank you madam chair i want to
recognize the work
that miss smarling
did to put this together there was a lot
of information and she
did an excellent job and i would like to
her recognized by our committee
yes we are here in fact we have to
specifically recognize her because she
injured her ankle yesterday and she's on
crutches
so look for
thank you
we are
[Music]
um thank you madam chair
can you hear me because you can't see me
can both here and see you all right okay
i just wanted to say that i will support
um
this amendment even though i don't agree
with part 10.
thank you very much is there anyone else
all right no further discussion the
motion is to approve an amendment
1579 h to senate bill 133
in the clerk representative roy
yes yes representative
pearson yes representative
yes representative yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lonzara yes
representative yes
representative goalie yes
representative yes sir
representative judy
representative schmidt yes
representative schultz
sorry yes
representative fellows yes
representative yes
representative broda we oc
representative o'brien
yes the chair
yes it is 19 to nothing on the invention
of the amendment
excellent in that case i move ought to
pass with amendment on senate bill 133
second here we go thank you rolling
yes i have nothing further to say
representative
thank you manager i think the uh bill is
amended
is um what we just voted on the
amendment so
nothing further needs to be said thank
you
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
on senate bill 133
right no hands nothing in that case the
motion is about to pass with the
amendment and the clerk control the rule
representative roy yes
yes representative pearson yes
representative yes
representative yes representative
allegro
yes representative bailey yes
representative sarah yes representative
yes representative goalie yes
representative shewan
sorry i couldn't get my mute off yes
representative judy
represented judy
we miss you we represent
yes representative schultz
yes representative fellows
yes representative franco
yes representative grota
yes representative o'brien
yes and the chair yes
it is the same 19 nothing the dots
what yes with amendments
does anyone object
thank you all because that that bill was
yes as someone said
it's a senate on the bus bill
okay thank you
all right senate bill 155 is
[Music]
thank
is there a second
this amendment uh is a result of
what i'm sure all of us know
here
you're in and out so i can't i'm so
sorry i
could you start over is that better
okay since i met that's better for the
moment yes
it's in my head i'll just start over
[Music]
this amendment um as a result of what we
all
i'm sure realize is a groundswell
of fear nervousness trepidation
on behalf of our constituents
with everything that's happening whether
you're pro-vaccine
anti-vaccine whatever side you are
whether your republican democrat this
comes down to a simple
thing and the question we're going to
ask ourselves is do we allow
what has happened with this pandemic
to change our history
forever we have
as a society always held our personal
health
and body to be the most sacred of our
rights what we do with this
the question now before us is are we
going to allow
department stores um
restaurants taxi cabs to determine
what vaccines we have to have
to either work there or use their
facilities
now we're dealing with this because of
covet 19 but this is not about covert
19.
this is about any future vaccine
that should come down the pike that
a certain facility business or whatever
decides that they want their employees
or their customers to have
as new hampshire citizens are clearly
telling us
that is the decision between them and
their doctor
so with this amendment i'd like to just
briefly
go through what we have included and
what we have excluded
with this amendment we tried to walk a
fine line
between one side that says no backseats
for anyone
and another side that says vaccinate
everybody
we dealt with health care workers to
ensure
that people that work in long-term care
facilities
that work in hospitals that deal with
potentially weakened immune system
patients
or themselves exposed to these type of
things
can be mandated by their employer to get
vaccines
quite recently over the weekend i spoke
to the um
lobbyist for the chiefs of the police in
new hampshire
excuse me fire chiefs and they were
in favor of this amendment so long as we
can include
first responders because they much like
other healthcare workers are often
exposed to bloodborne pathogens and sick
people
so we amended it and we added public
excuse me first responders so anyone who
works for a first
responder can also be mandated to get a
vaccine that is approved
we went through the part about schools
with children
we left all vaccines that are currently
mandated we left alone
all we did to change that is that any
future vaccines
that should be administered to our
children have to be approved
by the legislature currently it's just
approved by the head of the department
of health and safety
well if there's one thing we've learned
through this last year and a half
is that having one person in charge of
what we do where we go
when we do it is not a good idea and
extending that to what we put into our
children's bodies even worse
so if a new disease and a new vaccine
becomes available
it should not be difficult for them to
make the case to the legislature that
this is a good idea for our children to
have to have
so we dealt with that we also looked at
restaurants and businesses how else
could they deal with this
we specifically put in a ppp
uh note in here that says not
withstanding anything in this law
businesses can continue to mandate that
people wear ppe
either working or as customers so we
left that there
we tried to cover every possible base
but at the end of the day we have to
answer the question
are our citizens correct that their
bodies are their bodies
and they decide what happens with them
now
we've had discussions on other subjects
where often the phrase my body my choice
is used
and some people argue well that's not
necessarily true and some people argue
it is
i hope that the people that argue that
it is stand by their principle
and continue to extend it to this
situation because it truly is
your body alone and your choice as to
whether or not you get a vaccination of
any kind
furthermore this doesn't only extend to
vaccinations
if we allow businesses to decide what
people have to do to their body
to be employed or to be customers we
have to look at other things
they say well letting us have the covet
vaccine
is great it makes it a safer workplace
well what else makes it a safer
workplace what if next time
they decide to install bmi you have to
meet the government bmi
because otherwise you use too much sick
time and it costs more for insurance
or what if it's smoking or what if it's
drinking
there's no limit to what businesses
could do to citizens
who need a job or a place to shop or to
eat
we have to draw a line in the sand that
people their bodies are autonomous and
they're not subject to business they're
not subject to employment
without certain reasonable and limited
exceptions
we're talking about our future and we
have to look at this from a broad
perspective
and i hope that you'll support me in
thinking about this deeply
and understanding that this is not about
just covet 19
because before the end of the year kobe
20 could be out
and we'll need a vaccine for that and
we're already talking about boosters
we're going to need boosters so i'm not
sure about
all of you but i do not want target or
walmart
deciding when i need to get a booster
shot and what i need to have
or having to show them proof that i've
done it or
medical records showing why i can't do
it
thank you president
i'll just add uh two things briefly one
is
uh addressing the rest of the amendment
separate from the vaccine part i think
this
and the only thing i'll add on the
vaccine part is that
not that long ago the people of new
hampshire spoke
overwhelmingly that they when they uh
approved the constitutional amendment to
be
the first part of the constitution where
they said they uh
you know their privacy their private
information
was so critical to them that they were
willing to amend the state constitution
to uh to guarantee that and
i see a major part of our duty as
legislators and the purpose of
government
is to protect people's individual rights
and that is
a right of the people of new hampshire
and i believe
doing this is essential to that duty
thank you representative goalie
thank you madam chair i will be voting
against this amendment
i believe businesses are in a free
market
to determine themselves what is best for
the interest of their business
if those who choose not to work for a
business that requires
a vaccination so choose to they can go
to another place of employment
they know the terms and conditions when
they go and put their
application in for for that place of
employment
uh another reason why is uh the fact
that
it's going to end up being the
legislature making this
determination as to which vaccines are
applicable
i can't go along with that i go along
with the
science and the doctors and
one other reason i'm i cannot support
this uh
you know it's just uh my biggest issue
right now is
why this non-germain amendment is here
in this committee and not in health and
human services
when i looked at the listing back in the
doctor for the public hearing
health and human services still had
plenty of bills to attach a non-germain
amendment to
where this bill this nigerian amendment
should have gone to health and human
services committee not edna
so for that specific reason as well
i cannot support this um if they want to
bring it back
and send it over to health and human
services next year um
then i believe that's where it should
start and go to the floor from there
so for those reasons i cannot support
this and will not vote for it
thank you representative
thank you madam chair i will also not be
voting for this amendment
the covert vaccine is not mandatory and
people don't want to take it that's up
to them
and there's no consequences for that
other than
taking care of each other as a community
we
are responsible for public health and i
don't believe that the legislature is a
place to make those decisions
thank you fellows
thank you madam chair i can't support
um this amendment with the part that
we've just been discussing because it
can it will devastate some businesses
um cruise lines can't operate
safely unless they have um information
about the
vaccination status of the people who
want to go on a cruise
there was recently on tv a poll done by
unh that said a third of the people are
not
comfortable with the idea of going to a
concert
because obviously because they don't
want to sit beside somebody who hasn't
been vaccinated and it's not wouldn't be
much fun to go to a concert if you have
to
wear a mask and keep your mouth shut the
whole time
so um movie theaters
will also be impacted by this and those
are just a few examples
and the people who have been vaccinated
and want to attend these kinds of events
should have the right to do so and
their their rights to um
operate within the public space is
just as important as anybody else's
thank you
thank you representative
thank you madam chair um i have
several issues with the vaccine portion
of this
amendment also first
i paid special heed when we had the
hearing
that the human rights commission was
never consulted even though they were
included in this as enforcing body
particularly the portion that the young
lady testified to
that uh this is making a protected class
of people that's not delineated
how can you tell uh who you're
discriminating
against if you're not even allowed to
ask
that's also one of my own issues with
this
could possibly go along with
businesses not mandating their employees
to show a passport but to not even allow
them to
ask if an employee has immunity or been
vaccinated
how can they then determine who needs to
be supplied with
ppe if they're not even allowed to ask
and according to this language just
asking
would put them liable to a misdemeanor
to me that's just pretty much outrageous
finally i will say that i am
sort of resentful that this
amendment that everyone worked so hard
on
to put a lot of these professions into
the position of being licensed
is being jeopardized by the addition of
this
very controversial portion thank you
thank you representative
hello everybody good morning um
i don't want to hold up much more of our
time with um
reiterating what folks have said already
today um
but um i've looked at all the
information the same way
i also have to listen to the people um
i can't keep up with the emails with the
letters
and such and i've seen
and i've heard stories also of things
already happening to
businesses and they are being singled
out
um so again i'm the people
would like me to vote in favor of this
and i will do just that
yes i'd like to bring up some testimony
that was submitted
last week as well and
i'll keep my remarks for now limited to
that it's the testimony of dr raymond
walston who
ostensibly was testifying against this
amendment
and clearly he's all in favor of
vaccines and that's his
professional judgment and that's fine
but it was interesting enough to me that
i actually went to the
youtube video and made a brief
transcript of
a question that he was asked and his
response it can be found
on that youtube transcript of executive
departments administration at four hours
and 59 minutes and 25 seconds
to 500 12.
he was asked a question by a member of
the committee not me
and the question was and i quote do you
think it's appropriate
or even reasonable for a person of a
person or the government to ask another
person
or to discriminate against those
individuals based on your vaccine status
or immunity status
when it comes to matters of public
accommodation
his answer was i think that depends
so i would agree with dr norcasm in that
you can't globally group people together
and so if you say no we're not going to
provide services to any one person
because they don't have their immune
status
no i think that's wrong so here's a
fellow who came in ostensibly
testifying for one side but when he was
asked to speak
directly to the amendment uh his
testimony weighed in for the other side
thank you representative
thank you madam chair um i too am going
to vote against this amendment
um because of that section dealing with
vaccines
i guess i kind of look at it as i'm not
really sure it's about
vaccines or or what it's about it's
about
restricting private business from doing
business in
in the way that they want to um you know
i've been around long enough to know
that
um i've been i've applied for jobs that
they said you can have this job
if you get a haircut and i've had jobs
that i've applied to that said
you can have this job if you wear a
long-sleeve shirt that will cover up
your tattoos
and i've applied for jobs that have said
you can't wear that particular clothing
if you want to work here
and um and and i always had to accept
that as
if i want that job um then i have to
adhere to their rules whatever it
happens to be and if i don't agree with
it if i didn't want to get my hair cut
um then i had to go and work at a
different job and i did that
and uh and i think that that's the way
um
live free or die works in new hampshire
is that we
allow private businesses um to
run their businesses the way that they
see fit and the
uh you know so i think this is more
about restriction
of of trade than it is
um vaccines you know i mean we're
picking and choosing
which things businesses are going to be
allowed to do so
i too am sorry that this has become part
of
a bill of another sob bill that
um that i think a lot of people have
worked very hard on
and uh has a lot of good uh points to it
like
like uh senate bill 133 did
but um i won't be able to support it if
this particular
amendment is attached to it
thank you represent julie
yes madam chair uh also i'm not going to
vote for for this bill too
uh because i received so many emails
uh from my prostitutes i'm not even
receiving one who
who talked good about this bill
so because of that uh i'm not going to
support the bill
thank you thank you representative
yes i have a question on the amendment
why were measles removed and german
measles
kept in because german measles
if a pregnant woman is exposed to that
and catches
that excuse me representative allegro
has some data on that
yeah apparently that that was a
redundancy uh rubiola
is regular measles and as you know
rubella
is uh german measles so before it said
three kinds of measles for two did that
was that clear on that
uh yes i looked that up just before we
came in
because i had the same question uh so
it's it
used to say i think rubiola rubella and
measles
but rubio is and that's why
the other one was taken out
only need to mention it once yeah thank
you
i'm unclear now are you saying that
they're both they were they're both
removed from the original amendment
no rubiella um is in there
and rubio is measles so there was no uh
cause to say rubio and measles
current statute says ruby rubella which
is german measles
rubiola which is regular measles and the
amendment
some of the amendments we were talking
about earlier said
measles which was redundant and so
redundancy was removed
is that clear yes thank you
representative roy
thank you again matt chair um just a few
quick responses to what i've heard
um first of all since business
has actually been created the government
has been telling
business what it can do as far as with
human beings businesses argue that
we know we know how to run our business
best leave us alone
it's okay if we have children working
and we said
no it's not okay businesses said we know
what's best we know what our customers
want
we don't want certain people inside of
our eating establishments
it turns off other people and we said no
that's not okay
we have a history of allowing the free
market
and business to run as it should
until and if it impacts individual
rights to a statement made earlier about
the look free or die new hampshire way
live free or die does not mean
businesses live free or die it means
human beings citizens live free or die
so by cutting business loose to do
whatever it wants
to its citizens is not live free or die
live here or die is telling the citizens
that we're going to make sure your
rights are protected
comparing getting an injection into your
body
of a substance that could permanently
alter you
comparing it to haircuts and boots or
uniforms
or or such things um is species
at best and finally
when you say well if you don't like it
go somewhere else
where are you going to go when all the
businesses require it
right now in new hampshire and i've
circulated this two
large employers have already put their
employees on notice
get the vaccine or be terminated hence
the groundswell of emails
and that's two large employers and when
too large do it maybe two more
and two more where are you going to work
thank you
[Music]
all right i'm going to
want to make their second or third
remarks after i make my short remarks
uh i'm not talking specifically about
the vaccine
section to which we have
incidentally another amendment that
simply
stops before we add that in but
on the section for the
uh local zoning i mean the uh
outdoor dining we got a
very late like yesterday comment from
the liquor commission
and the restaurant association that they
were concerned that
on page 5 lines 16
that if they have a sewer system they
need approval from des for any expansion
under this section
i thought that it was clear but
obviously not
that we meant any expansion of
number of people served
because you know people want to sit
outside or they may be
spacing tables further out than they
used to so there's not as much room
inside
they're concerned that if they added a
patio it would be considered an
expansion
and didn't want des approval
and i can't see that that would be
necessary but
i wanted to bring that to your attention
i'm concerned about that particular
language
okay representative schmidt
thank you madam chair uh
well with regard to this last issue uh
it it's very unfortunate uh that we are
uh encumbering i even want to say
contaminating
the very good work that this committee
did uh
especially the subcommittee on the
underlying senate bill 155
where we made a number of improvements
both in conjunction with at the request
of
businesses and the commission liquor
commission and so forth and so on
and we came up with something that uh
i think we was quite understandable and
was even an
improvement on what the senate had sent
us unfortunately we've encumbered it as
i said contaminated it
with this non-german amendment uh which
i'm also
not going to support and thus i can't
support the entire
uh amendment um and um
so let me raise my points uh with regard
to the non-german amendment
um first of all uh i
want to begin with associating myself
very strongly
with representative goalie's uh
remarks with regard to this committee
being assigned
or being targeted if you will with this
non-german amendment
we are not the policy committee for
medical issues
we are not the committee of jurisdiction
we have no real expertise in this even
if we have
several firefighters as our committee
members who have some medical background
that they are undoubtedly going to split
along party lines here
um so this is
completely wrong and as a matter of fact
because this
non-german amendment has been so
controversial
and we are now getting a new version of
the non-german amendment
this morning or at least that's when i'm
getting it
that we haven't even probably had
properly had it and uh the opportunity
to to vet
uh and this is just totally not only
improper but it's
counterproductive in terms of
just good prog process um
so i i strongly protest the fact that
this
non-german amendment is in front of this
committee
we are not competent to make this call
except to recognize that this is such a
hot potato
that we should not be doing it at all in
my opinion
um and so
that that
uh is point of reference uh but
the the underlying thing is and i've
received hundreds of emails as well
overwhelmingly in support of uh the
non-german amendment but most of them
i know addressing an issue which is not
really even on the table
most of them have spoken to so-called
vaccine passports
and also mandatory vaccination
now the state has long provided
exemptions
from medical procedures for people who
are
medically compromised in a way that they
can't have that procedure and that's
appropriate
totally appropriate and i support that
100 percent
i also with some reservations uh
but nevertheless support the idea of a
religious exemption
philosophical exemptions i'm very
troubled by
because that basically says i don't like
this i don't want this
um i don't think that's very
good grounds in view of the fact that a
lot of the people who have written to me
don't really understand what they're
talking about
or they're basing their opinions on on
on information which i think is
questionable at the very least
but this is but the the bill is actually
a false premise
because vaccine passports and mandatory
examination
vaccinations are not on the table here
and for the people who are watching this
and who will be watching this because
it's being recorded and it's going to be
posted
and the citizens of new hampshire who
are concerned about this have a right to
understand where we're coming from um
and this is a this is a false premise
uh because uh vaccine passports
are not on the table i and i
i'm not at all sure that we have a good
grasp on this committee and what vaccine
passports really are
we have a concept there's been some
discussion of it
but not really sufficient um and
and the original amendment i'm not sure
that i
can find it in this amendment would have
banned any documentation
regarding vaccinations well i've had the
the covid 19 vaccination the pfizer
vaccine both shots i'm totally protected
i had no reactions whatsoever of a
negative sort
um and so
i'm under the information i've received
i'm now protected against
covert 19 and all of its variants that
we know about at this point
i'm comfortable with that i'm also
comfortable with people who
uh who are medically fragile
who cannot for one reason or other be
vaccinated
they shouldn't be vaccinated putting
themselves at risk and they're not
being required to be vaccinated the
hospital association and the doctors
that
testified before us they they said
you know they have worker the hospital
association testified
they have workarounds they are
enabling people who cannot be vaccinated
or for
religious reasons perhaps also cannot be
vaccinated or won't be vaccinated
that they have work around so those
people can protect themselves and the
public
so so you know
that's mandatory vaccination is in my
judgment
not really on the table certainly not
the way that the
supporters of the non-german and maine
amendment think
it to be the case as far as
vaccine passports as i say the original
amendment from representative baxter
you know specifically had the language
no any documentation
regarding vaccinations well when i got
my vaccines
they gave me a card they had my name my
date of birth
the lot number of the vaccine and the
date
and when i came back from my for my
second shot
they entered in the the the date and all
the pertinent information as well as the
lot number
well that would be prohibited under uh
the baxter language for sure
but that would be a violation of federal
law
the the the there's a record being made
of the fact that i've been vaccinated
and i can to the degree that it's
necessary i can present that car
to show that i've been vaccinated
that would be prohibited under under the
baxter amendment and i think it's
not sure if it's in here or not because
this new amendment
changes from things that no i don't it
hasn't even been properly vetted
so this is you know th this
is a a bad amendment because it it
demands things that the the so-called
threat assessment that has been
consistently part of the not only the
baxter amendment but right on through
including representative roy's that
would put
the hospitals through you know
individual assessment
they have thousands and tens of
thousands of
employees who work for medical
professions
medical occupations they would all have
to be individually assessed
what is that going to cost in time and
money
and to the degree that nursing homes
which are initially were not
exempted but are subsequently i believe
included but who knows what is what's in
this
this new version of it
uh i believe 11 county nursing homes
uh in the state of new hampshire would
all be
under this one way or the other
especially if they're exempted
and but they would have to jump through
all these hoops as well
that's a 28 age which has never been
raised but is a germane issue
even if the amendment is non-germane
the 28a issue and the costs imposed on
the counties
that is the germain issue namely a 28a
issue
so this is uh this this this
this bill is something of a of a red
herring
uh and i want to specifically object
and protest against the very common
assertion
in the emails i received that we are
looking at nazi germany
uh with with the with the desire
of the medical profession to protect us
against this uh pandemic
for god's sakes this is a respiratory
disease
if there's anything human beings need to
do it is to breathe on a very very
frequent basis
uninterrupted for more than a minute or
so
and therefore any disease that is a
respiratory disease
is of significant jeopardy to the people
of this state
and therefore i believe that businesses
have a right to protect themselves
their employees and the public
in a number of cases not always
but many business would have would
absolutely have a right
to protect the public as well as their
their employees
from uh from the the ravages
of coven 19 and it's not just some
little flu
uh you know like disease even the flu
back in 1918
wound up killing something like 50
million people worldwide
and millions in this country and this
pandemic has killed almost 600 000
americans
so this is nothing to fool around with
and this um this
non-german amendment is fooling around
with it so
there's no way i'm supporting this
thank you representative schmidt
representative
thank you madam chair um and i think
what representative schmidt the main
points he was saying
are somewhat what i wanted to say so i
won't reiterate them other than to point
out that
um i think that 90 of what
representative roy
was saying i think we can all agree on
we don't no one's asking for a passport
no one's asking to mandate vaccines for
all who
would be by age eligible
um i don't think we disagree on that
certainly not on the my my body my
choice part
i appreciate the point i really do i
think that
what's important to my constituents
and to me is just how
so much of this discussion beyond that
is has just had such a negative impact
overall in our society but too much of
this has started to sound like the
scopes
monkey trial to a degree and i look
forward to the day when we can have
bipartisan discussions involving science
that aren't political
um so i will also be voting against this
amendment thank you representative
yes i um agree with representative
schmidt
uh it's something that we've been saying
for well over a year
and that is people need to breathe
the other thing i thought was very
interesting was
we've heard this argument before on
another bill that we faced in this
committee that was controversial
it's not happening in this state and we
focus on the specific language vaccine
passports
the other thing was happening in the
state
and this is happening in this state so
we need to protect people
against a violation of their rights but
you don't need to be an expert
to see what this is all about and what
the reality is
about this amendment and the way people
are coming down on sides
and and by the way i'll i'll add no i
won't add my own background i'll just
leave that be
but just looking at the way that this
bill was argued debated
about the testimony given i noted the
usual tactics
of witnesses and others unfortunately
characterizing
data as misinformation or lies
false information or implying that a
huge volume of messages and this was
this was implied at our last hearing
implying that a huge volume of volume or
messages
uh in support were insincere or made out
of ignorance
when i see the internal contradictions
like hyping the development of variance
to stoke fear
while at the same time mandating a
vaccine that almost certainly will be
less
active on those same variants and last
and most entertaining
when i hear people opining about the
rights of businesses to conduct their
own
uh business without interference from
government
[Music]
from a body and individuals
on any other given day do that very same
thing for a hobby
so when i witness an argument written
with defamation and
so many internal contradictions i don't
need to know anything about science or
viruses or immunology or pathology
which by the way i do to know that
this is a good amendment and a necessary
measure to protect the rights
of citizens of new hampshire yes live
free or die
representative
thank you madam chair i will just add
that
comment that i heard previously about
some large corporations in our state
uh beginning to mandate that their
employees be vaccinated
i would just point out that if we
end up passing this and making them all
guilty of a misdemeanor for doing that
uh chances are good that they will
move their businesses and their jobs out
of state
because they have the interest of
protecting
their workforce um they can't afford
to have a large percentage of their
workforces
decimated by some future pandemic
thank you
i'm sorry who did you call on you
oh i withdraw my comments oh i'm sorry i
do want to make one comment because
i want people to know this as well that
this
um amendment does not
allow agents child
care agencies child care agencies
to require that their employees be
vaccinated so that
a woman is pregnant who is
also schools a pregnant woman could work
at a school
catch rubella and her fetus would die
so i want people to understand that this
is a serious thing and i don't
understand why
this is an issue within this committee
number
two um i do think that
we have agencies state agencies who have
expertise
and we trust them with many parts of the
state
and there's no reason why we can't
protect we can't trust the department of
health and human services
in this state thank you
representative bailey i've heard
in opposition to this that if i was to
have
a tattoo or a long hair
or something like that i'd be
prevented from getting a job and that
would be okay i could just move on to
the next job
but i've also heard that if companies
face these kind of restrictions they'll
move out of state
and we need to cater to that well why
aren't we catering to the individuals
this would be my question
thank you is there anyone else who
wishes to speak on this
efficiently all right uh in that case
the motion
is on amendment 1685
made by representative roy
[Music]
amendment 1685 h
representative roy yes
clark votes yes representative yakovich
yes representative lekkis yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative renzara yes
representative santonistasso yes
representative goalie no representative
schuett
mr clerk i didn't hear you call
representative pearson
but vote no pearson is the clerk
representative
oh i'm sorry thank you
i vote representative judy
no mr representative schmidt
no representative schultz
reluctantly no representative fellows
no representative fontenot no
representative grota no
and finally representative o'brien no
yes and the chair
yes it always takes a while to train
without to nine
so the mission fails motion fails
madam chair representative schuett is
first
yes manager is it possible to move
um the rest of that amendment without
the
uh vaccine portion we have an amendment
number for that i believe do we not
we have such an amendment and you may so
move
i moved on second
second divided by schmidt and the that
amendment is
i can look up the number as well i'm
trying to search for it
we're going to double check the number i
think it's 16 or 47
excuse me miss darling but that one
includes the childhood immunization no
it's 60
it's 600 you're right
i apologize all right representative
you're moving amendment 1646
right nothing whatsoever after the uh
clicker fees correct yes
and it also is an amendment that no
longer includes a sunset date for the
outdoor dining language
since the provision not clarifies an
existing law
rather than creating a new law we had
that kind of glitch
that was repaired this does not have a
sunset
correct okay that's amendment 1646
moved by representative schuett seconded
by representative schmidt
and mr clarify madame
this has nothing of the
you're correct nothing of that of about
vaccines or
or anything to do with that the
emergence the non-germain amendment
simply is our amendments and to the
original senate bill 155
very good thank you do you care to speak
to your mouse
well i believe madam chair that um i
hope
that all of the members of the committee
appreciate
the work that the subcommittees did on
this bill
and all of its various pieces and that
everyone
certainly would support this
thank you representative schmidt
only the same adam chairman it was a
good bill when it came over from the
senate and
the subcommittee and this committee have
improved it significantly
so let's all support supported
is there anyone else
seeing no hands
box
[Music]
are we taking a short break here madam
chair
yes i think she just announced a short
caucus
okay thank you
um
this
while we're waiting i just want to say
hi to former representative bowden
hi i know you're not on our side of the
panelist for you
but you know we're waiting you know that
he's there how do you see him
he he he's one of the attenders
and i appreciated him steve i thought
you moved to north carolina
he can't talk can he only if we let him
in
i there's a good joke there but i won't
well it's good to see you
representative sarah are you waiting for
the uh meeting to start or do you want
to say something
i did i just want to confirm the last
number of votes
well say hello first but um just wanted
to
confirm was that nine nine that we had
on the last one
it was yes it was it was in the uh
prior on 133 wasn't it
19-0 it was
who's missing representative
had left the room
okay that's why i was unclear who was
calling the role
same here
and to think i almost went in person
today
what would you be thinking that you
would do that or
recording oh well um
i have a shorter commute
though with the new cdc announcement
about
compromised immune systems has held me
back
well did you catch the story about the
breakthrough that there have been
several weeks ago they said 179 people
in new hampshire that were fully
vaccinated got covered again
one of them died and nine of them were
hospitalized
we're not you know i think it's going to
be good this summer but i think when we
get to the fall we're going to
start seeing more cases again
well i assume those who had covered when
they were vaccinated
but i don't know no well
no i don't i don't think so because they
said fully vaccinated which would mean
you know if you get two shots
it was two weeks beyond the two shots
well you could have caught it um
just before your second shot
and not have built the army that the
second shot gives you to fight the
illness but it would have had to hold it
off
for more than two weeks because these
people
didn't present or weren't diagnosed
until
two weeks after their second shot look
we're talking about the vaccine
well i think you know the depending on
the shot you got i think it's like 96
percent
right but but for the second shot you're
only like
50 something depending on the shot
covered
so it's sort of a flip of the coin
before you get your second shot
i know you said fully these are not
these are these are people who are two
weeks beyond their last
shot
170 is a pretty high percent
i what concerned me was the fact that
there were also nine that were
so sick they were hospitalized but i
haven't heard
any details if it's six percent of the
people
who've been fully vaccinated it's
probably way less than six percent
if you do the math because how many new
hampshire have been fully vaccinated
what
well the other aspect is it depends on
what vaccine they got
the pfizer and the modern is are up in
the mid 90s
the j as i understand it is only about
60 percent
uh you know effective which is still
pretty good
and better than no vaccine but that if
that was what they had
then then they uh you know
they're running a risk of still getting
it the question is
how bad is the case and you're saying
that nine of them were hospitalized and
one died
so that's who knows that's
yeah yeah
but that's one of the things that the
medical people told us
no vaccine is 100 effective and
therefore
uh the the herd immunity aspects and
so forth and so on are all factors in
the outcome their caucus has
taken quite a while sally
yeah we should tell representatives are
waiting are we just
i just is the recording still running
yes
yeah yes reporting is running throughout
this whole thing
so it has not stopped running i'm just
letting you know i'll know and they're
still in caucus
i think i think we should shut up and
not talk
this is not appropriate to waste the
public's time
listening to this chatter well i just i
just
think this is pertinent according to
wmur website 342
000 in new hampshire have been fully
vaccinated the percentage of 149 people
comes to 4.3 percent
well within the range
4.3 179
is four point three percent of what
i thought she said 149 it came to
whatever it is point zero zero four is
what i got oh
well point zero zero four is not
maybe it's four that's four one
hundredths point four percent
yeah not point four point zero zero four
yeah so that's to my point
pretty darn good that's well within the
uh
the range that they said would
not be effective
um we don't want anyone to pass away
from this
obviously no absolutely not but the
the point with uh that amendment was
that you would not be able to tell
if you're going into a business uh as
another client
or if you're an employee you know
who who should you stay away from even
if you've been fully vaccinated
if we could work we're still being
recorded
um damn we should either shut the
recording off until they come back or
do something to mute everybody i believe
uh
it looks like the room well the video
just came back on
yeah i i'm afraid to
turn the recording off i believe that i
i don't know how it gets restored
if we were to turn it off okay
well i would just i would suggest to my
caucus members uh fellow caucus members
if you want to have a conversation i
would
ask that you take it offline amongst
yourselves
point taken thank you so we have the
video back in the
um committee room but we don't have the
audio
if if the intent was to unmute
thank you representative lucas
i thought i got the um
fine we are we have completed our caucus
thank you very much all right is there
any further discussion
on the amendment 1646
[Music]
which is where we were
not seeing any the motion is
ought to pass amendment 1646 h to senate
bill 155
and the third controller representative
roy no
the clerk votes no representative
yakovich
no representative no representative
allegro no
representative bailey no representative
lanzarra
no representative santana
no representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative
judy we miss you representative schmidt
yes president schultz
yes representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
yes and i'm very sad that we can't
support the committee's work on
representative o'brien yes thank you 99
as well
i vote no and you vote no of course of
course
it's it comes with the territories clerk
you always forget your chair
okay while we were caucusing i consulted
with the clerk
this is not a surprise and he assures me
that it is possible
to put in no recommendation
with two ought to pass with amendment
recommendations rather than an itl or
not to pass
since that seems to be the sense of the
committee
that the
one party prefers one amendment and the
other party prefers the other amendment
but we all agree we don't want the bill
without
any amendment uh i will
unless the strong objections from the
committee we will make itself
well it seems to me if we have a
non-germane amendment
that uh where the motion of ought to
pass failed
you're not recognized representative
thank you madam chair uh just to be
clear if
if this goes forward without
recommendation
it will come before the house with an
ought to pass motion as it came to us
is that not correct that is not correct
i i that was one of my concerns because
we don't want that
i that's what i was speaking to the
to paul smith about and he says that it
would be perfectly
appropriate to have two recommendations
ought to pass with amendment
one by one side and one by the other and
therefore we would essentially be
debating the the amendments
because i can't see anybody that wants
to pass the bill as it came to us from
the senate representative
for the clarification thank you manager
yeah and i just wanted to clarify that
as well that the
motion would be ought to pass and then
the amendments would be brought up
with the out to pass motion so that
would be
uh the procedure yes
yes there would be no committee
amendment but there would be
two different recommendations each will
be with an amendment
that's agreeable
okay so other than the general
issues alvarez and bully that you you
had more to say
yes i did and i'm sure i just did while
we're on the issue and if we're
going to go with no recommendation i
just want to state my
disappointment in um i think the
committee did
real good work and getting some uh
things hashed out
in the original amendment of senate bill
and it's unfortunate that we're going to
go to the floor without recommendation
on knowing that the work we did on that
amendment
was uh for the good of the people here
in new hampshire
and i just and disappointed that we
the fight for the amendment um
vaccination amendment
uh doesn't go to the floor on its own
merits instead of
being uh caught up in the work that we
did
it's just an unfortunate thing it is
unfortunate but i think the uh
if the debate will be on the vaccine
section because
all right representative schuett uh
since you made the motion
would you write a report on how to pass
with amendment 1646
i would i would first ask
my caucus leader if he would prefer to
have his name on the report
i would defer to him if he chooses i
will
let you fight that out among yourselves
between the two
together thank you i need that by
early tomorrow morning at the latest all
right
representative roy will be writing one
for what to pass with amendment 1579
sorry i've already sent in the one on
senate bill
133 this is a rather disappointing way
to
end this session but uh thank you all
for your work
we have actually gotten a lot of very
good work done
this session and i hope
i don't expect any committee meetings
until we
have to deal with uh
deal with budget yes representative
schmidt
until we have to deal with senate
amendments so far
the only amendment that i've seen is
uh totally innocuous it's only
on the wentworth cheswell bay
all right representative schuett yes i
was just
curious if you had a feeling when we
would be
likely to be taking those up
according to the speaker it's like we
might
we will probably not take them up the
next session where we have to get all
the senate bills out
but on the 10th we will be taking up the
concurrences
and setting up committees of congress
thank you madam chairs by me
i would just like to state
that i formed a a
friendship with former representative
dave danielson when we attended
the ncsl conference in los angeles a few
years ago
and was so sorry to learn of his passing
i was planning to take place in the
drive-by which had been scheduled
unfortunately the day
after he passed so i just
wanted to state that
for all committee members to honor his
memory
thank you absolutely
uh representative schultz did you have
something
yeah well i agree with represent what
representative schuett said
um any of us who got to know him liked
him quite a bit and
it's a great loss that's not why i raise
my hand um
i just like to request um the list
of retained bills and who's of
in charge of them and who's on which
committees i assume it will be the same
grouping i can't hear you very clearly
sorry hey is that better
yes much better i just wanted to request
a copy
of the retained bills and the
assignments to whom
they are assigned oh gosh my english is
bad right
send to that email oh thank you
no the deadline is in it's in the
calendar it's october sometime i think
but i really recommend that each
subcommittee meet
while we're still here to plan what
you're going to be doing
like it then now the next couple of
weeks whatever
okay representative schmidt
thank you madam chair i had raised my
hand also
uh to speak with regard to dave
danielson whom i knew quite well
in his five terms with us
a true consummate gentleman a gentle
person a really
gentle person and i was stunned to learn
of his
hospice situation and the fact that he
passed so quickly uh before i could even
uh think of uh communicating with him
directly or with his family
is a personal loss to me because he was
a friend of mine and
i'm i'm very very very
heartbroken by his passing
we don't submit any liking all right
thank you very much i was i didn't know
him as well as you did
but uh again it's it's
such a shock when somebody that you last
saw
good health it's gone that quickly
absolutely
thank you my manager i just wanted to uh
quickly address the
committee um we deal with some pretty
passionate issues um we're passionate
people
we're intelligent people and um just
like with sports
i'm gonna leave it on the field and i
hope you'll do the same you're all my
friends
i respect each and every one of you and
we come to
uh sometimes some pretty passionate
disagreements
but at the end of the day um we all
serve the same purpose
so i appreciate all of you thank you
thanks terry all right and on that
respectful note
we'll close this meeting and uh
i'm sending out a note of who's speaking
on which bills
for one month when the calendar comes
out
thank you